Một mấy bà giờ bị chi tân á thấp nhận đối ở vào khoảng mấy mấy độ bị bác,
một trong mấy chiến phẩy mấy độ kinh đông trên phùng viện phía đông năm khu vực bóc biên đông.
Sức giò mạnh nhất của gần tân á thấp nhận đối mạnh cấp sấu,
tức là tử khoảng 3,5% đền 1,5% giật tốc tâm dí chuyển theo hưởng tài bắt,
với tốc lộ từ 5,5% người kí lo mẹc, một dơ, dự báo đến một dơ ngày 1 năm tham.
A thúc nhìn đợi trên vụ biển phía đông năm khu vực bóc biên đông.
Dí chuyển chắc theo hưởng đông bởi xức giò mạnh cấp sấu, dật cấp tâm,
đền 100 bà giờ ngày 1 năm tham.
A thúc nhìn đợi trên khu vực phía bác nảo lúc giáu của HP,
Chúng ta sẽ không có thể đông đồng năm khoảng 1 kí lưu mát mùi giờ xích gió giữa cấp sấu và suy yếu dần thành đồng á thấp.
Giò anh hưởng của á thân nhìn đối trong chiều và đêm 1 buồn thả tảm, vùng biển phía đông năm của cuộc bóc biển đốc.
Còn gió mạnh cấp sấu, giờ cấp tảm, sống cao hai đến bà mết biển đốc.
Truy nhiên, giữ báo á thân nhìn đối khó hoàn hưởng đến vùng phát biển và đã tên liển của biển năm.